FOR PETS,
I'M IN TOTAL CONTROL.
- DR. ARMOND SHOULD
HAVE HIS OWN SHOW.
- BUT AT HOME,
ALL BETS ARE OFF.
THAT WAS THE THIRD TIME
THIS MONTH.
- THIS IS NOT WHAT
I SIGNED UP FOR.
- DAD, BRING ME
A CHOCOLATE MILK. IDIOT.
GO [bleep] YOURSELF.
- THIS IS
ARMOND OF THE HOUSE.
- ♪ STANDING ON A DOCK,
LOOKING AT SOME WATER ♪
- OH.
LOOK WHAT THE CAT
DRAGGED IN.
[video game beeps]
GOOD MORNING, ROMAN.
- SHH!
- TAKE OFF YOUR HEADPHONES
WHEN I'M TALKING TO YOU.
WHAT, DID YOU JUST SEE THE MOVIE
ANGER MANAGEMENT?
- GO [bleep] YOURSELF.
- YOU READY FOR
YOUR BIG DAY TODAY, HMM?
[basketball bouncing]
[hoop swoosh]
[crowd cheers]
- I DON'T WANNA
PLAY BASKETBALL.
- ROMAN,
WE MADE AN AGREEMENT.
YOU WILL SPEND MORE TIME OUTSIDE
AND THEN YOU--
- [spits]
- I THINK THAT BASKETBALL'S
GONNA BE A GREAT WAY
FOR ME AND MY SON ROMAN
TO BOND.
- THE PRODUCER SAID I HAVE
TO PLAY BASKETBALL TODAY.
[bleep] YOU, DAD.
- YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
A REACTION OUT OF ME,
BUT YOU WON'T.
- BUCK, BUCK, BUCK, BUCK!
MAKE ME EGGS.
- YOU WANT EGGS?
- YEAH.
- WITH TOAST?
- NO, ON A WAFFLE SANDWICH.
- LIKE A MONTE CRISTO.
ROMAN, I CAN'T DENY YOU WANTING
THE FINER THINGS IN LIFE.
YOU HAVE SEEN YOUR MOTHER,
AFTER ALL.
- EWW.
- ROOM SERVICE
AT THE HOTEL ARMOND.
- UGH, NOT ON THE MOUTH.
- HOW ARE YOU FEELING TODAY?
- I'M FEELING TERRIBLE.
- OH, MY DEAR SWEET.
YOU MUST
TAKE IT EASY THEN.
WHAT CAN I DO TO
MAKE IT UP TO YOU?
- MY FRIEND DINA WANTS
TO SHOW ME A NEW JEWELRY LINE.
- DINA? WAS SHE
THAT ONE WHO SENT
THE MASS EMAIL ABOUT
HER MISCARRIAGE?
HOW ABOUT THIS?
- ♪ HALLELUJAH
- YOU GET YOURSELF A LITTLE
PIECE OF JEWELRY FROM DINA,
AND THEN WHEN ROMAN
IS PLAYING...
[hoop swoosh]
[crowd cheers]
THEN YOU AND I COULD--
- WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
- I'M MAKING
A SEXUAL INNUENDO TO YOU.
- IT'S NOT WORKING.
- I KNOW.
- I HATE YOU!
I HATE MY LIFE!
- WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHIKK KLUB,
STOP IT!
[car horn beeps]
[tires screech]
- TURN AROUND!
- ROMAN, STOP IT!
[cars honking,
tires screeching]
[funeral music]
[police radio chatter]